(exhales deeply)
- Man, I'm glad to be back.
It's February, 2021.
And I just had a birthday
early this month,
February the 18th, and
I turned 54 years old.
Never thought I would get here.
Now that's a blessing.
Sometimes if I feel like it's a curse,
nah, I'm just bullshitting.
Now but for real, for real,
and I owe it getting to
this stage of the game
to being committed
and I've never been committed to anything
not in relationships,
personal relationships,
jobs, in anything else,
except when it came to making a commitment
to the motherfucking gym.
That's the only thing that
I've been committed to.
And I've been a partner
with for the past 30 years.
I hooked up for crack cocaine.
That shit lasted for a while I
was back and forth in and out
but I wasn't committed to it.
It didn't last as long as this,
committed to going to prison,
did that shit about 19 times.
I don't know how many years
that have suck the out of me
that my life in that area.
Rehabs, 30 of them motherfuckers,
but I didn't make that kind of commitment
to those places like I
did to the gym overall.
The gym, that's who carried me through,
that's who came through
when this shit the fan,
when all of us failed.
There's always some
things that take place,
man, in my life where I really
have to take a step back
and take a look and say, "I get it."
Or "I understand now."
Or it's like, somebody
hit the light switch
and the light comes on and
I say, "I understand now."
And that's where a gym comes in that.
I remember, man, I started
this commitment to working out
just so I can be able
to take care of myself.
Growing up, I was always
tall, I was skinny
and I didn't get picked on
as far as like by bullies,
but I had a hard time at it, man.
Just dealing with my sibling,
had an older brother,
chip on his motherfucking shoulder.
And eight out of 10 times,
he took it out on me.
And I think I endured that shit
from like eight, nine years old
till maybe I'll was 17 years old.
So say 19 years old to up to 17
that was the day that I took my first trip
to the state penitentiary.
So I remember back then
I got caught on strong armed robbery.
They sentenced me to 16 months.
I was 17 at the time turn into 18.
So they said, "Okay, by
the time you turn 18,
your ass, you'll be right for prison."
Because in order to go
to the state penitentiary
we had to be 18 years or older.
17 years or less that's
juvenile hall, juvie.
And so I was right, man, for that.
But lo and behold, man,
I've got the prison
sit my ass up there to Jamestown
went to motherfucking power camp.
I was up in the mountains, in the cabins
eating like a king.
And guess what they had
up in there waiting on me,
weights, I was in heaven.
To attest shit, I went right
back again in under two years.
Next time he sent me, they
sent me for four years.
I couldn't wait to get back
because they had everything
that I've ever imagined
that I didn't have on the
streets I had up in there,
a safe haven, a place to
get away from everything
and every motherfucking
body including myself.
But what was integral
about that whole experience
was the weights, man.
It was the transformation that took place.
Now the transformation
didn't take place mentally,
psychologically or spiritually,
the transformation took place physically.
I was transformed from
a scrawny little kid
to like the, God is my witness,
to motherfucking incredible hope.
I left the prison so big.
I didn't even recognize myself.
My family even did the double-take
they couldn't even believe it.
And that's what set the ball rolling.
And that's what, (chuckles)
That one guiding force
has been leading away
thus far for the past 30 something years.
Transformation.
I didn't see it but
other people saw it in me
before I could see to myself.
And then when I finally got around
to seeing it for what the it was,
I couldn't even believe it.
Who, me?
You got to be kidding me.
'Cause I've always been skinny.
I've always been thin.
First with my feet and all that bullshit,
can dance real good and all that.
Kiss the football real good.
I remember being a kid, we used to climb.
We used to go in the alley
stack about six, seven mattresses, man.
We'd climb up the telephone pole
get on the tallest roof
and jump off the roof
into the mattress and flip.
I'm talking about three,
four stories, man.
And you know how dangerous that was?
But back then, it wasn't
nothing to us, man.
'Cause we just needed something to do.
That was it.
I remember running into burning buildings
and all that bullshit in disguise
or going in there to save a cat or a dog
or a little baby or something.
It wasn't nothing in there that was just,
we had to think of something
in order to do some crazy shit like that.
And that's what we did.
That's what I did as a kid.
Shit like that, man.
Running through traffic
and all that bullshit,
try not to get hit like
the game you're in.
That's what I did, man.
What I now recognize a
transformation for what it was.
It changed everything about me.
The way I thought, the way I
feel, the way I saw myself.
Well, it didn't change that
part to where so myself,
because by then I was consumed
or I was taken in by
what other people saw me,
what other people's
perception was, so I got lost.
I got lost in the other people's appraisal
and in accolades and all that bullshit .
So in other words I was lost in the sauce
before I'd even know what it was.
I'll come home after
10 months in fire camp,
swollen motherfucker.
Didn't do nothing with it.
Got back into the same old
shit caught another robbery
went back for four years would have.
Did about 26 months and some days.
Came out twice as big, twice as strong,
twice as fast, like the
bionic man, $6 million man
bigger, stronger, faster.
Hell, yeah, that was me in full effect.
And what happened was I
didn't wanna go right back.
So I looked up into
something that helped me
kind of keep me on the straight neural.
And at the time when I was coming up,
they had YMCA's, YWCA's
and all that kind of stuff.
And this was back in the 80s.
Back in the early 90's,
I think 24 Hour Fitness just came out.
So I was gone.
I think I went to prison back in 89
and I paroled in like 91, close to 92
and 24 Hour Fitness or health
clubs is out there, man,
the gyms and I'm like,
"Man, let me sign up."
And that's exactly what I did.
And I've been dealing
with the 24 Hour Fitness
and I've 30 plus years.
We have this relationship that is so,
(exhales deeply)
it's crazy, man.
I didn't take advantage of the gym.
like I should have.
I didn't use it for what
it helps me for now.
Back then I was just using
it for just the outside.
'Cause that's all that mattered to me.
I didn't give a fuck about
nothing but the outside.
What the fuck you thought
how you feel on everything?
I've been in a relationship
with a woman, man.
And if I'm laying the dick good,
if I'm staying on swollen
the motherfucking gym
and if I'm doing everything
I'm supposed to be doing
to make her happy, then
I'm cool, I'm in heaven.
But let me not meet one
of her expectations.
Let me disappoint her, or
some shape, form or fashion.
Now I'm walking around
like a piece of shit.
Like the weight of the
world is on my shoulders.
It's a beautiful day,
but this dark cloud is hovering around me.
Where the fuck does that come from?
I didn't have a clue because my worth
was based on some other
person's perspective of me, man.
How they saw me was so motherfucking self.
I couldn't see me back then.
I was lost back then, man.
Shit, I was invisible man
Up until just recently.
I've always been invisible man.
I never saw who was looking back at me
in a reflection in a motherfucking mirror
even way back then.
I wouldn't admit it back then
like I can admit it today.
Man, there's so much more to it than that
but I'm gonna keep it on the gym.
So my worth was based on how
other people saw me, man.
'Cause I couldn't see me back then.
All I knew I found something at work
that got me a lot of attention
and it was good attention.
It was attention that made me feel
like a king on a throne.
I remember walking down the street,
motherfuckers doing the double thing.
Man so light me up on the inside
but I wouldn't show it
you wouldn't know it.
She used to kill me.
I remember just laying in bed at night,
going over the days comings and goings
and all my little places that I've been in
and different people's reaction.
Men I've been asleep and I'd be laughing,
and tossing and turning,
giggling kicking my feet,
and flopping around like
a fish out of water.
You know what, just that jubilation man,
of the effect that I cost.
That shit was crazy.
I swear to God, God is my witness
and not use the gym, for
what it was worth man,
and it got me through a lot of hardships
and got me through a lot of
scrapes and a lot of, man.
I use the gym and my body
to get me through my 20s, 30s, 40s.
So that means I have to rely on the gym
where I didn't graduate from high school
but I had that motherfucking gym.
I didn't have a work history
but I had the motherfucking gym.
I had crack on my motherfucking back
like it's King Kong but I had the gym.
My life was totally in ruins
man, but I had the gym.
So I thought the gym would
solve all my problems
in all those areas.
And it took me, man, a
lot of trips to prison
to figure out the gym wouldn't solve that.
A lot of trips to rehab
to figure out the gym
couldn't save me from that.
A lot of trips to being homeless
to realize the gyms couldn't
keep me from going there.
Because I was using the gym
for all the wrong reasons, man.
I wasn't using it to help me
in a ways that it was meant to.
I was using that shit
to build up the outside.
What was killing my
motherfucking ass from the inside
was me not looking at me,
man, for who I was, man.
For the things I didn't do
that I should have done.
So I'm using the gym as my
motherfucking scape goat.
If it wasn't for the gym, I
probably would have been dead
or it wasn't for the gym, I
probably wouldn't be dead.
I probably would've been this or that.
The gym only did what it
was supposed to do, man.
And that was to give me something
that I didn't have, man.
But it was real because the
transformation did take place.
I just wasn't ready to
accept it for what it was.
I'ma share something with
you, this shit is deep.
I've been in the gym
30 motherfucking years.
I have the opportunity to
train four people, four people
in my 37 years.
And I saw the transformation take place,
a name motherfucking life.
So I know what's real, that's my gift.
It didn't save them from
motherfucking on hardships.
It didn't save them from broken marriages
or whatever the case, or
bankruptcy, or some shit like that.
'Cause it had nothing to do with that.
I got to see the
transformation take place.
Just like the fucking caterpillar
going to the (indistinct),
coming out as the butterfly,
that kind of transformation.
I've got to see it and that's real.
That's my gift.
That's what I owed to the gym.
I don't walk around with no billboards,
I'm a trainer and all that shit.
I wanna have no motherfucking
cards made up personal trainer
will train you and all that shit.
Will train you for food
and some shit like that.
On the side of the motherfucking
freeway with the sign,
will train for food or for
money or crack or whatever.
I hate that kind of partying.
I don't put it out there.
If you happen to see me in a gym
or any motherfucking where else
and you wanna get together and
partner up, then I'm willing.
I'll do it.
I'll take you up on your offer
because I know if I
don't train nobody else
while I'm on this earth
then God won't be mad at me
because I helped four people.
You know how many people
helped me over the years
or try to in other areas
where the transformation did take place?
Transformation, that shit is so important.
But the cool thing about it
it doesn't take a whole bunch of people.
It's that one-on-one kind
of transformation thing
you got to do, you got to
have, you have to experience.
My transformation happen to prison.
One motherfucking man,
you didn't take the
whole motherfucking yard.
You didn't take the SEAL prep class,
church, Islamic services
education and all that shit.
Train them motherfuckers on the yard.
It didn't take all that one
person, me dealing with him.
And it happened, goddammit and this real.
So I know what's real.
The fucking I'm talking about.
I've been in the game long
enough to see it for what it is.
I was just using it for the wrong reason.
(exhales sharply)
The transformation is so
real, so serious of me.
I get a lot of people
asking questions at the gym
or in the streets.
Check this all, I remember in prison.
I have so many people coming up to me,
"Man, I wanna work out with you.
Man, I wanna train with
you and all that bullshit.
Now mind you, my last shift to prison,
I did like six and a
half years on one yard.
Went away for a minute, came back
but that's previous.
But for the most part,
man, I was in one spot.
And before I parole from that
motherfucking, I was training.
I was training three different dudes
and it took up seven days of the week.
So I stayed busy.
I stayed on the yard seven days a week
working out, stayed in education.
Did the SEAL prep classes,
church, Islamic services
and all that other
bullshit that came with it.
Okay forget, worked in the kitchen.
Mind you, I'm training seven days a week,
but before I can lock in that four,
the three people that take up
the seven days a week for me
leading now to a parole
from that motherfucker,
I experienced hundreds of men
doing that six and a half years.
All want to work out.
All want to train with
you and all that bullshit.
Come on board, man, I got you.
Meet me here, meet me
there, meet me out there.
Go through a workout session.
Might not see them the next day,
might not see them for
another motherfucking` week.
You know how many scores a man
tapped out early in the game?
Did they thought I was bullshitting
that I wasn't serious
about my motherfucking craft and my gift?
See, I didn't know I had a gift back then.
I thought my gift was dead,
the pipe, the anaconda
whatever fuck you wanna call it, the body.
I didn't know my gift
was much more than that.
So leading up Into our parole in 2017,
once that transformation took place
everything came full circle.
And I knew just exactly
how important working out
helped me through those trials and errors
of those motherfucking trips to prison,
in those trips to rehab
and those many countless
vain of chimps man,
I'd get my shit together.
But still ended up on the side
of the motherfucking freeway
off ramp off there in
the San Fernando Valley.
I see why gym was important back then.
I see where it came in and helped me,
navigate it and deal with that shit.
Even though I wasn't trying
to see it for what it was
'cause I was the invisible man back then.
But that gym was real.
That's the only motherfucking
thing that sustained me
through those trips to prison,
through those rehabs, man.
And I was homeless and campless, man,
it was a motherfucking gym.
That was the only thing,
that was the only thing that
I had solid to stand on.
And it stood the test of time
and it's still doing it today.
More so than never, I rely
on it more now than never
because it's real.
It no longer took me to realize
the real transformation
that took place in my motherfucking life,
I'm not gonna even say
it, I'll be embarrassed
and you guys would be shocked.
So I'm gonna keep that to myself.
More of it will be reveal.
But for the most part,
mind, body and spirit
it encompasses all of those things.
Like I said more so now than ever.
So the transformation took
place in prison for me.
And once I saw it for what it was.
And once it hit me and I
saw where we're training,
fitting, what part that played in it,
I secure three men, seven days a week.
I have one for two days,
one for two days and one for three days.
And prior to that, guys were just,
one week here, two, three days with me,
four days here, maybe eight, nine days
working out with me and tap out
and all that kind of bullshit.
But after that metamorphosis
with this one man
before I paroled, I had to
sigh Korean guy, Mr. Lee,
I love Mr.Lee, 'cause he
was always there on time
and I hated Mr. Lee too 'cause
Mr. Lee had money, big money.
And I remember when he first approached me
and we were talking and after
he left people was like,
"Hey man, you know who that was?"
I said, "Yeah, Mr. Lee."
They said, "No, that
motherfucking is a millionaire."
I'm like, "What you mean?"
Said, "He's the one that,
He's like a, he had those places
like those fucking smoothies,
those berry smoothies.
And, but he sold his
whatever you fucking call it,
we have more than one of his franchise
His franchises before he came to prison.
Got millions for it."
I said, "Okay, but I feel bad because
he didn't tell me that."
Lee (indistinct) to me making this,
finalizing our little deal
how much I would charge
then maybe month to train a man.
And I said, "Well, check this out, Mr. Lee
I'll charge you $40 a month
just to train you man,
how many days a week?"
"I don't give a fuck
man, I'll be out here.
Just let me know."
He said, "Let's try four on, three off."
I said, "Okay."
And what made me mad was,
he didn't tell me who he was beforehand.
I would have charged him a
whole lot more than $40, man.
So that's where that real
transformation take place
'cause you really know your worth then.
I know my motherfucking worth.
I know it wasn't your average
job when it came to training.
I don't know I had a
gift in that area, shit.
But what happened was he
flipped the script on me, right.
So after about year of being committed
to my motherfucking training
this is how he paid me back.
He would get me here.
He would say, "Okay, give
me your list for the store
for the 40 bucks."
But every quarter in the package he say,
"Eric, what kind of tennis
shoes would you like
for this quarter, man?
Pick up your pair."
I'm going, "Fuck, how much they cost?"
"Give me a pair of tennis."
When he had the food sales.
I don't care what it was, every food sale.
"What you want from the food sale, man?"
Man, I take the, say it was in and out.
"Give me the double burger
with the fries and a shake,
and throw in some cookies on the side."
And he would do it.
Pizza, same thing.
He'll order a whole pizza for me.
Chicken, the whole chicken.
He did that for me.
So it wasn't that he was shortchanging me.
No, I've got mine on the backend
but that was what was important
because I didn't think he
saw my work, but he did.
So even though he said,
"Check this out, Eric
the only reason why I'd never
paid you more than the $40
you asked for in the beginning,
because I'm a businessman.
And I stick to my word."
He says, "So I had to show you,
I'm teaching you in business
always get this shit out in the front,
whatever it is, wherever you see yourself
then let them know if
they accept, it cool,
if not, then you're going
about your business."
He said, "I'm a businessman, I had,
that's what you told me, 40 bucks."
He said, "I'm cool with that."
He said, "I don't mind paying more money,
but I'ma keep you,"
He said, "I'ma to keep you,":
What was that word it was the
same he used to say back then?
I'm gonna keep you something, man.
Anyway, man, I'm gonna keep
you honest in that area, man. "
So he said, "But next time
don't never say no shit
like that no $40 man."
He said, "Cause that's really,
you said it's not a (indistinct) buddy."
He says, "Just by me being
with you for about a year man,
money can't pay what the
transformation has taken place."
And what he meant by that was he says,
I think after maybe
the first three months,
he's married and everything.
So he used to do those
family business in prison,
but he said his wife noticed
the transformation taking place.
She knows the separation
from the shoulder.
She knows the little muscles in his back,
during little love sessions.
And I think at the six months, man,
at the six months of
our training, he said,
"Hey Eric, man my wife told me
to tell you thank you man."
And he broke down.
I said, "Man, what you're
breaking down for?"
"Because," he said,
"My wife was so she just
couldn't believe it, man."
He says, "I've been with
my wife over 20 years."
He says, "She ain't
never reacted like that.
She never was really that surprised
when it came to touching and
feeling and all that stuff.
He says, "She was so into the touching
and the feelings and exploring me
by the different body parts."
He says, "Man, it blew my mind, man."
And that's when he knew that
the transformation was real
'cause he couldn't see it but she did.
Used to tell that motherfucker.
I said, "Thank you."
And she meant it.
And when he told me, I knew he meant.
It'll probably take a lot
for him to even confide
that shit to me.
You have to understand man
being in prison and
having that kind of money.
He had a lot of millions running
around that motherfucker.
He had somebody washing his clothes.
He has somebody holding his phones.
He had about 70 lockers up
and that motherfucker full of stuff.
So we had a lot of
people doing his bidding.
So it took a lot for him to expose himself
to me like that in that area.
But he had no choice, motherfucker,
'cause it was real.
That's when I knew.
I know my gift.
That's just one example.
That's this one man.
But he lasted 18 months
with me on a regular basis.
And the day I parole, he
was right there with me.
The day I parole we was out there,
only your trainer.
The day before I parole,
out there with me.
And I remember up until
maybe, I paroled in 2017.
I remember maybe a year or two after
was at my scene man,
that I was in prison ward
and they used to say, "Hey
man, you're the trainer?
Hey man, I remember you man,
you was the one fucking barking out
seven days a week on the yard."
And they used to tell me,
"Hey man, the SEALs and some of the guards
still be talking about your
man using you as a reference."
A lot of inmates was talking
about you in the yard
using you as a reference, man.
Remember that black dude, man?
The tall black dude?"
And I knew right then and there
that me being in prison,
me having that transformation take place,
I left something good
on that motherfucker.
I didn't leave that motherfucker,
with my reputation perceive
me in a negative way,
I left there with my reputation
perceive me in a good way.
Motherfuckers was referring
to me as a trainer.
I'm not no motherfucking trainer.
Yes I am.
I'm not no trainer, yes I am.
I'm not no trainer.
I'm not gonna buy that.
But see, that was a reference to me
and I almost been in to it, but I didn't
because that's not what I was there for.
Training is one thing,
but then transformation
is something different
entirely, man.
And if you get that shit twisted
then you'll never get
past point A to point B.
That's why I was stuck in point A
for so motherfucking long
because even though the
transformation took place
I was stuck in the mindset of the trainer.
So it didn't help me
mind, body, and spirit.
It just helped me in a
physical from the outside
looking from the outside perspective.
But there was so much
more to it than that.
Once the transformation take place.
And I know, man, it's not about the train.
It's about what happens once that happens.
Your whole motherfucking life change.
Everything changes,
not just on a physical,
on how you see yourself.
It's not so much how other people view you
or what other motherfuckers say about you.
But it's how you see yourself
and what you say about
yourself to yourself.
That's the transformation right there.
And where does it help you?
Out outside of the body.
And I got a small taste
of that man for Mr. Lee.
Mr. Lee was the architect.
So he would get me on the weekends
to come to a little arts and crafts class.
And he'd be showing me
these different designs
and all that kind of stuff.
I'd be like, "Oh my God!
Man, how'd you learn this?"
"In college."
"Oh, my bad."
That was above my pay scale.
So those are the
conversations we didn't have,
'cause he was on a
whole nother level, man.
But when that transformation happened,
he dropped it down to
my motherfucking levels.
So I can get a sneak peek
at what he was dealing with.
He said, "You know what,
Eric, when I come home,
I wanna hire you, man.
I want to get you hooked up with me
so I can open up some kind of enterprise
to get you in there somewhere,
fit you in there somewhere
where I can help you."
(exhales deeply)
Mr. Lee wants to help me when
he gets out of prison succeed
because of what I did in there for him
because it wasn't about
no motherfucking training
that wasn't, native as a transformation.
He got it.
I got it.
It's more than training.
It's how you see things.
Everything you see is different.
You might be going through the same shit.
You might be going through
the same thing in prison
or in your relationship or in your job
and that kind of stuff.
But the way you see it is different,
that's the transformation.
Then you now it's real.
It took my partner, Curtis
close to three years
of dealing with me one-on-one
for that transformation to take place.
It took Mr. Lee, about nine months
of me working one-on-one
with him through training
for him for that
transformation to take place.
So it's different for everybody.
And it works in all kinds of skill sets.
I don't give a fuck what it is.
Mind, body, and spirit
that transformation can take
place in each and every area.
All is one or a one or individually,
is different strokes for different folks.
You have to run across that one person,
that one man or woman that
you meet or you're counting,
you're like, "Man, goddamn,
baby I changed motherfucking
every thing for you.
I'm won't rob, I won't
I steal, I won't cheat.
I won't do nothing."
And mean that shit.
That's the transformation
I'm talking about.
Meeting that special someone.
That is how you do things
you never thought you'll
do do in your entire life.
Going back to school.
Learning how to become a truck driver.
Doing everything in your power
to make sure that she's happy, she's okay
because you gave her your word
that you would take care of her,
you'll be the best man that you can be
and live up to that
motherfucking standard.
Back up your words through your actions.
If you've never done
that, your entire life.
That's the kind of
transformation I'm talking about.
(exhales deeply)
I think Mr. Lee should be
out in another two years
and I know he's gonna be true to his word.
He's still in there running shit.
He's still a millionaire.
He's still...
People still talk about Mr.
Lee and all that kind of stuff.
I keep my ears, close to the street
and all that kind of stuff.
And I stay in contact with some people
that go to CRC once a
month doing those panels,
different panels.
(indistinct) AA, NA those
kinds of panels, man.
And you know, I'll call
every now and then,
they get, "Hey, what's going on?"
"Oh, I went up to CRC last month.
So you know every,"
They let me know what's going on.
And I haven't heard anything in a while
because of the COVID-19.
But before then, I was
getting a monthly update on
what was going on with
the particular people
that I had that close relationship with
when it came to the training.
And Mr. Lee, he was at
the top of the list.
'cause everybody knew who he was.
But the way it helped me out there
was the way it helped me in there was,
he got me to see it
wasn't about me training.
It was about me giving something
that would make a person better.
That'll make him a better
man or better woman.
Make them do things they
never thought they'd do before
or go where they never
thought they can go before.
And it wasn't just on the training, man,
'cause when Mr. Lee broke it down for me.
He met me at my level.
He said, "Check this out, Eric.
No, you ain't been to school,
but I would suggest this."
And he run them down to me what was like
for him being in school
when he was taking the architecture class.
He broke it down to me, told
me what the classes was like,
the time he had to put into it,
the commitment and all that shit.
He even talked about his
relationship with his wife
and what it meant to him and
how important it was for him.
When he met her, he said
he was a certain kind,
he was a tough guy
because he knew that,
a lot of Asians know what that,
was he a kickboxer?
Thinking he was in a kickboxing.
So he was a tough guy, but she told him,
she didn't want a
motherfucker that was violent.
He said, he didn't do no
more fighting out of anger
when he met her.
He said he stopped that.
He didn't do no more fight.
And when it came to that's
the thing, kickboxing.
He said he gave it up for her
and that's when I knew,
the transformation is taking place.
He had that transformation in that area.
'Cause I had mine.
So I recognize his.
And when he shared it with me
it just confirmed everything
that it just came full circle.
So I'm gonna get up the person
to get up to the now.
I need the gym like the
air that I breathe, man,
to make it through today.
Got the COVID-19 motherfucking
and all that bullshit
and my world's been turned upside down.
It helps me.
It helps me, man, when I'm wanna go left,
when I wanna give up and
feel sorry for myself.
'Cause I just don't feel,
I feel like at 54 motherfucking years old,
I should be somewhere else,
in another time and in another place.
I should have been in a
relationship with Ms. Right.
Should have the house, the car,
the kids in all that shit, man.
I don't have none of
that and it's killing me,
'cause that's what I want more than ever.
Never been married.
That's one of those unspoken prayers
hasn't been answered, is killing me.
There is so much I want out of life, man.
And it's not a whole lot
because I've found what I need
and that just being okay with me
being comfortable in my own skin,
the good, the bad and the difficult.
But that gym, goddammit,
that's my foundation
because I know that's what
transformations take place.
Not for my sake, but for your sake
if you ever run across me
and you make that commitment,
then you see what I'm talking about.
'Cause it'd be real for you
just as much as it's real for me.
But the beautiful thing about it
is I get the watch it take place.
I get the help it, come to past.
Shit is gonna take time.
It's gonna take energy.
It's gonna take effort and
all that bullshit on my part.
I'm going to have to show
up each and every day
and give you all that I
got to give in that area.
And got to lead by example.
I came to sit on mats to say,
"Oh you need to (indistinct),
you need to do (indistinct), the five."
Hell no, I'm up in that
motherfucking with you.
Get behind me, man.
Get your ass on my shoulders
and get on my back or whatever.
But we're about to do this.
That's the kind of motherfucking
effort I'm talking about.
Being right there with
you, every step of the way.
That's my gift.
That's my gift,
That's what I have to offer today.
Something real, something
tangible, transformation.
Money can't buy that.
You can't even put a price on that
because that's something nobody
can ever take away from you.
Once it happens, you can never go back,
not to where you came from.
You'd be like, "Oh, hell no."
Moving forward to here.
Putting one foot in because you know
that what the fuck I'm
talking about is real
because it's real for you.
Like it was real for me.
Everybody has their gifts, man.
Everybody has their talents, man.
But to witness the transformation
that's something different entirely man.
One of these days or one of these times
I'll have to talk about
the transformation man,
because that's so important, man.
That's the platform.
That's the springboard
for this whole new world
opening up before your eyes, man.
The transformation for me,
it's like, man I'll walk
and encounter every day
as a brand new day, man.
I went to the gym this morning, got back,
feels so motherfucking good.
Cleaned my little apartment up.
Listen to my music and
took a shower, laid down.
I was looking at a movie
and I'm sitting in my bed,
eating this big bowl of raisin bran
with sliced bananas in it, right.
And I'm just giggling and laughing
because I feel good all over.
I feel like a million dollars.
Because I've got to do what I love to do,
what I do best.
And I did it for me, for me.
It's so important that I
set aside some time for me
If you had a whole block full of people,
wanting to be trained that was committed,
goddammit would I be there
for each and every one
of them, individually.
But I still have to set
aside some time for me
because I need that too,
because it's like the air I breathe, man.
It's not my foundation,
but I know what's real.
And when it works for me,
it works all areas, man.
Keeps me from the bullshit,
keeps me out the bullshit.
The keeps me from no
places I shouldn't be,
doing the things I shouldn't be doing.
And the people I shouldn't
be doing with, man
because I'm like this, man.
I'll get to carry some
change in my pocket today
and every now and then I'll see
a wondering women out there.
I know she's out there hustling
trying to make her money.
And Lord knows, I'd like
to contribute to her cause.
Hey, I'm human fair exchange, no robbery.
How much?
That's you girl.
Thank you ma'am and I'm gone.
But the gym keeps me from going there.
I get frustrated, man.
So what the fuck I do want
to get back from the gym?
Take a cold shower.
That's should a pass.
So I be on the bus, in the trains
and I see a lot of those women
and some of them are
looking at me like, "Mm-hmm"
I'd be like, "Mm-Hmm."
But I know better.
I know what comes with that
and I'm not willing to take that chance.
So it works in all areas.
I just don't have enough
time to go into detail
but I think you get the picture.
It's the best thing
that's ever happened to me
because I got to see it
for what it really is
and what it really means, man,
and how important it is
when it's all said and done.
It's not the motherfucking foundation,
but it's a piece of the puzzle
that brings it all together, man.
And I couldn't have one without the other
but then the cool thing about it is
everything that I've experienced,
all the things that's
been added to my arsenal
or to my tool chest, it compliments, man.
Everything complements the other,
this part complements this.
This is part complements that.
This will make this a little bit better.
This part, this aspect makes
us a little bit better.
So everything's coming together, man.
And before you know it,
I'm gonna be inside this complete circle
and I'm gonna be the little thing,
I'm gonna be the one in
the middle that surrounded
by the herd and protected and looked over.
And that's exactly where I wanna be,
in the middle surrounded by the things
that's helping me and bolding me,
and making me bigger, stronger, faster,
but in the areas where you can't see it.
But I know what's there.
And I know it's real
because everything that's
happening that I encounter
is for the good, is for the betterment.
I'm adding to some shit today.
I want the skills that
really pay the bills.
I need skills that pays bills,
not just by hearsay,
by word, but by action.
And that's what I get from the gym.
It helps me, mending those errors,
it helps me be a better painter, floor,
wood finisher, fucking sea mandarin, cop.
I don't give a fuck what it is.
But it's letting me know that
when it's all said and done,
if you ever want to
encounter a transformation
in that area and you know where I'm at
and if you don't believe
me, take me up on it.
I've got you.
I'll be right here waiting on you.
Thank you.
(exhales deeply)
- [Man] Dude, that's good.
- [Eric] Was that good?
- [Man] Fuck, nobody
talks like you, nobody.
- [Eric] Was it good though man?
- [Man] It's fucking great.
- [Eric] Okay.
- [Man] You're doing better
and better you're still,
you're amazing.